I understand this mentoring that I do
with you has now you are now mentoring
Pete Davidson yeah well yeah well people
don't realize that Pete Davidson of SNL
yeah you discovered him kinda yeah you
never I gave him a platform I hate
saying I discovered people and
especially like with someone like Pete
always heals a man you're always talking
about me [ __ ] about you Pete they bring
you up but but the thing is I was doing
morning radio here at your old station
right karahan I would do a comedy night
every every month and I would just bring
up people and this kid who was like 15
years all used to call the station like
every day like yo man I put me on I was
like this high school and the one that I
was like yeah you know what buggy you
could come to the show he came to the
show Rock he's a very funny guy and I
took him on tour he opened up for me I
put him on wiling out all of that stuff
and then he got and then he got the job
on that show so since he was a 15 yogi I
made him finish high school before we
went on the road and then like his mom
was so sweet and then obviously he
shared the story about his father he
made a whole life and I got really close
with the family and and he's my brother
and he was calling you during all that
crazy did you even give him female
advice yeah well I got my own [ __ ]
female problems I told him just have fun
and enjoy it I thought it was funny that
you were giving him fever because you've
got a complex situation going on there
there's nothing simple in your life
exactly when he was with Ariana Grande
it looked like a home run to me yeah I
told him I was rumble young man Rumble
this is unbelievable but okay that ended
and you said you need an older woman
yeah this is something you know about I
do I love doing Robin you know but this
Pete Davidson I like this and you say
you know out with an older woman and you
advised him yes Kate Beckinsale would be
good for you and employ you were bright
I was he's he's enjoying itself you are
earning that turbine yeah I mean I used
to see the terminations little
pretentious
you know swearing yeah ya know now I'm
thinking about it ago maybe you deserve
it B levitating